you got to meet the kids who start in
the first movie yeah correct and what
was that like was I mean was it
important to establish a connection with
them in order to play not at all already
here
no I met Wyatt we still don't talk yeah
no it was very sweet what the kids did
for all of us they wrote these uh these
letters as the kids to our their future
adult selves of what they hope for those
characters of their lives and and how
did how they their wishes and dreams for
them I think the weird thing though we
all kind of had a laugh about this was
they gave us picture frames of them as
their characters and we were like
getting a good laugh about like so we're
gonna so let's get the stares we're
gonna take these pictures I have a
picture frame of Wyatt a boy young man
young man and what am i till I put it on
my mantle and his friends are gonna come
over me like he's a little boy on your
man so it's on my mantle that same
feeling when they gave those pictures
that was such a nice gesture we all were
like I don't want to
[Laughter]